les chéris vous savez que c'est la
dernière de yassine belattar ce soir oui
et j'ai une surprise pour lui vous
verrez ça dans un instant c'est parti
yassine belattar et eric sarrat moyens
d'abord moyens sinon tu peux faire ton
fric mais je crois que tu auras pas
chronique ce soir c'est vrai non je te
le dis je te le dis ce soir c'est ta
dernière chronique de ta saison tu t'en
doutes pouvait pas rester sans rien
faire et on a avec nous au téléphone ce
soir quelqu'un qui voulait te dire
quelque chose et surtout qui nous a
ramené des docks cdp dossier sur toi
avant d'avoir la personne j'aurais
d'abord qu'on voit des petites ces
petites choses sur toi
regardez j'ai retrouvé ton album photo
regardez comme ils étaient beaux
celui-ci des plis non mais regardez
comme il aimait aussi sera au régime
alors et regardez regardez
yacine déjà en maillot mais t'es pas mal
il chausse du 42 est chaud du tarn
regardez non mais t'as l'air tous âges
je suis sale regarder à la hausse en
qu'il commença et par quoi ah là là il
ya de l'huile d'olive avec la moustache
à c mais c'est mais c'est oui mais c'est
pas sa réelle qu'il a mais c'est déjà
déjà tu étais déjà des gens mais c'est
incroyable 18 ans d'amour [ __ ]
célébrer mme basset sebhaoui son
partenaire m'a dit ah oui on peut dire
thomas idée là d'ailleurs sans que cela
va la plus longue pour cette conférence
et des devoirs qu'elle maurer et j'ai
quelqu'un au téléphone qui va qui
voudrait écouter ta chronique ce soir
bonsoir
allô allô allô oui bonsoir flammia
bonjour madame vous êtes la maman de
yacine sa maman et sava damian damian on
va écouter la chronique de yacine et est
ce que vous pourriez lui mettre une note
à la fin
d'accord
ça va vous vous allez bien oui par l'ama
vous le regardez tous les soirs
qu'est ce que vous pensez de sa nouvelle
barbe que je fais tu sais bien ouais il
vous fait rire oui bientôt ria que moi
oui damien juste peine que je vous
donnais question est ce que vous
regardez jusqu'à ya la chronique de
l'acide ou vous regardez toutes les
missions après vous êtes un amour
franchement je vous aime damien merci
beaucoup et vous êtes fier de yacine
bien d'accord vous écouter on voit là
bas nous c'est notre site à dernière ce
soir il reviendra l'année prochaine
c'est gentil vous le suivrez l'année
prochaine aussi
oui voilà mais ton marinella ou pas en
tant que c'est pas lui qui a appris au
téléphone je ne sais toujours pas ce que
je fais dans la vie
savard maman ça va je crois qu'elle a
plus envie de vous parler combattants
n'ont pas je suis très déçu il ya c'est
une fois qu'elles plongent ou par les
nazis boy acide alors là elle va nous
écouter damian je lui fais un gros bisou
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer c'est un
d'amour est venu voir les signes dans la
foi n'est pas bien la via domitia
[Applaudissements]